all right all right so i guess this
kind of connects but the question is
can you explain imputed right righteousness
imputed righteousness is what god does for us in
part of the righteousness imperialize imperializes
what he does in us uh when you come to christ
he's sinner i'm sorry forgive me immediately
christ's righteousness covers you and
his righteousness stands in your place
now listen to what you said stands in your place
let me put it this way you're in school university
of missouri city and you get f e g plus h
minus those are your grades are you with me
now you come to christ and you submit to him read
out christ's score for me a plus a plus a plus a
plus a plus plus plus those are the grace christ
has in righteousness he puts that to your name
when you come to him let me
tell you why that's necessary
a perfect life the bible says the law of the lord
is perfect a perfect law requires a perfect life
you said amen but did you get what i'm saying
a perfect law cannot tolerate an imperfect life
if it tolerated it it ceases to be a perfect
law a perfect law demands a perfect life
which means you have to be
perfect in the past in the present
and you must be perfect in the future are you with
me the only person who's lived that life is christ
so when you come to christ you truly surrender
you convicted by his love as expressed on calvary
you want to do everything that pleases him but
the spirit is willing but the flesh is me you
understand christ accepts you and covers you with
his righteousness and so eloise writes in step to
christ page 62 paragraph two if you give yourself
to him and accept him as your savior then sinful
as your life may have been for his sake
you counted righteous christ's character
is put in place of your character and you are
accepted by god just as if you had never seen
okay okay give me one minute one this
is so astounding people don't believe it
they don't believe it the gospel is
the most astonishing that's why angels
cannot understand it that the very
listen to second corinthians 5 21
for he god the father hath made him christ
to be sin for us whom you know sin that's
christ so you know sin that we might be made
the righteousness of god in him we must be
made righteous because we cannot make ourselves
righteous god was god made jesus to be sin because
jesus never made himself sin by sinning and so
imputed righteousness is what is given to us
when we come to christ the important righteousness
is that power that takes us from day to day one
is our title to heaven that's imputed the other
is our fitness for heaven for instance let's say
my little brother is 12 and he's next in line
to be king of some country in europe somewhere
but he's only 12. now he has to wait till he's 18.
he has the title but he does not have the fitness
are you with me let me say it again he has the
title but he doesn't have the fitness so when you
come to christ i'm sorry like that publican
in luke 18 he left with the right the title
he now had to develop the fitness or christ had
to work out the fitness in him and so imputed
as a title imparted provides the fitness
for a place in god's kingdom yes my brother
one second hold on a second please mike because
the people we wanted people in line to hear
so what you just explained then the dilemma in
the church now is what we hear people will be
sinning until jesus come no no no no no look
at look at daniel daniel loved god so much
when he had a choice between sin and
death finish my words he chose death
we have to come to that point look at the three
hebrew boys who refused to bow they had a choice
between bow and live and refuse to bow and die
they chose death not knowing they be saved paul
went to jerusalem acts 20 saying i know what's
waiting for me but i don't count my life pressures
when you see hebrews 2 14 verse 15 for as much
then as the children are partakers of flesh and
blood he also himself likewise took part of the
same that through death he might destroy him
that had the power of death that is the devil
and delivered them who through fear of death
were all the lifetime subject the bondage genuine
surrender to christ brings you to the place where
you prefer to die then knowingly sin against god
no we will come to the place where we will not sin
believe this we continue sinning to jesus
listen to me god put adam out for
one sin he can't let you in with one
you